for me
connectivity in the future is about
invisibility
it's about not even thinking about how
and when you're connected
whether it's a device or wi-fi or
um you know 5g however it is that all
your bits and bobs are connected you
don't even have to think about it
and that allows you to participate in in
a life that we're starting to see the
buds of as covet takes hold we're seeing
actually you can visit your gp
online let alone all the other doctors
that we would all like to see in a much
more convenient way
and then you can have your children
educated but what about adult education
what about the ability to travel
immediately to other places
and enjoy experiences with people from
all over the world and certainly
having festive occasions with your
family wherever they may be because
we're locked down
or just because we're traveling in a
different location so for me
connectivity is absolutely an
opportunity for us all to engage in more
of a global community with both our
friends
our family people we may not even know
yet and also be sure that we can support
the social services that we all need in
a much more efficient basis
so i'm really looking forward to
connectivity in 15 years
you